hi I'm Nicolas be with Matt Welch this
is ask a libertarian 2012 we're
celebrating the upcoming release of the
Declaration of Independence in a new
updated paperback this question comes
from Dana Thompson via email as a 20
year old libertarian I'm often told by
older liberals and conservatives that I
will learn more about the world and grow
out of it any suggestions on how to
respond to such a condescending
statement I'm not sure why you'd want to
ask another older person like Nick but I
for one can say that look they may be
right here 20 things change in your
brain but most likely they're wrong in
that sense that right now as we talked
about in the book um 40 percent or more
of Americans self-described themselves
as being independent they don't have any
natural affinity for either of the two
major political parties or any other
party for that matter that isn't an
all-time high it's much higher than
people who affiliate with Democrats or
the Republicans and that trend is even
stronger among young people so young
people are more independent and young
people are also more libertarian
especially on attitudes having to do
with civil liberties and drug war and
elsewhere so chances are they're wrong
but hey you're 20 you're an adult you
can shrug it off and and go forth hey
you know the other thing to think about
is that conservatives and liberals the
way that they function in political
parties and in other ways they're the
past then they know that the past 10
years have not been kind to them they've
both gotten their chances to run the
country and they've pretty much driven
it off a cliff the future belongs to
libertarians to people who believe that
individuals having more control over the
things that matter most of them in their
lives and their right and ability to
live how they want to that's the future
and I think these people will love you
know you don't have to explain it to
them just show it to them while they're
checking out your dust and the future of
today involves more ask a libertarian so
keep watching and keep sending those
questions